[Music]
the jackass movies have made half a
billion dollars at the box office but
one of the stars of jackass forever is
having some trouble paying his bills
okay
things are getting a little too gnarly
right now things are going too far some
might make the argument that due to the
physical jeopardy they routinely put
themselves in for our entertainment the
stars of the franchise jackass deserve
to be in the top tier when it comes to
financial compensation in the
entertainment industry after all not
even the infamously courageous tom
cruise exposes himself to poisonous
scorpion stings or participates in high
impact hidden camera pranks while
filming the stunt heavy mission
impossible series and so far ethan hunt
hasn't even been shot out of a cannon be
that as it may life isn't always just
her fair which means that the lovable
jackass performers who put their bodies
and their egos on the line just to get a
laugh from the audience aren't
necessarily making eight-figure paydays
in fact it's possible to be a breakout
star the most recent jackass feature
film jackass forever and still be pretty
much completely broke you know i don't
let that get to me dude i just want to
be by the beach surfing and chasing
chicks my whole life so it can be easy
to make the assumption that just because
a person is famous they must also be
rich but that is sometimes far from the
case especially when you can become
famous on a platform like the jackass
franchise which despite its pop cultural
ubiquity and big studio backing is still
a relatively low budget affair according
to variety jackass forever costs just 10
million dollars to make which isn't a
lot when you consider that it had to be
spread out over the film's impressive
roster of new and returning franchise
performers so it shouldn't come as a
complete surprise that one of the stars
of that film doesn't exactly have the
wealth to match his on-screen bravado
one of the leading lights of jackass
forever is franchise newcomer sean
poopy's mcinerney and not just because
of his extremely memorable nickname one
of his exploits in the film involves
getting personal with the texas
rattlesnake a harrowing stunt that
eventually earned him an mtv movie award
for best kiss anyone who would share
intimate screen time of the rattlesnake
probably deserves a bump in pay but in a
recent appearance on the podcast stevo's
wild ride the surfer and jackass star
admitted to being flat broke it's safe
to say that
that you didn't get paid a whole bunch
to be in the new jackass movie poopy
said he understands that as a newcomer
to the franchise the studio was likely
reluctant to give him a huge paycheck to
sign on to the film considering they
hadn't really seen what he could do yet
stevo also noted that with something
like jackass there are probably many
eager teenagers and fans who would
participate just for the fun of it as
steve-o put it the people who sign the
check see participation in jackass as a
privilege and they don't necessarily
have to pay through the nose to get
unproven and untested talent despite his
previous appearance on a jackass shark
week special poopies was basically a
newcomer to the series when he appeared
in jackass forever and it sounds like
the paycheck he received for the film
wasn't enough to keep him in the black
poopies even said that he recently
didn't even have money to pay for gas
hoobies explained simply i'm broke a
situation that may seem unusual for
someone with a prominent role in a movie
that has grossed more than 80 million
dollars worldwide right now if i show
you my bank account it's in the red
then he added that two years of kobe
related delays on the production of
jackass forever created additional
financial difficulties furthermore
poopy's admitted to not exactly having
accurate expectations about his own
financial situation he said that he was
relatively free with his spending and
the time after the jackass shoot as he
believed there would be more money
coming around the corner that ultimately
didn't arrive even with his financial
difficulties poopy seemed in relatively
good spirits and stevo even stepped in
to promote his co-stars cameo account
and merch store to get some more money
headed his way of all the people for
poopies to have it aside during this
time stevo is probably one of the best
after all the longtime franchise veteran
has been open about the fact that he was
broke when jackass first started airing
all the way back in 2000 from those
humble beginnings he managed to carve a
nice niche for himself in the
entertainment industry and perhaps with
the right guidance poopies can seize on
the success of jackass forever and do
the same check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you